bonsoir nous sommes le 5 janvier 2015
bienvenue pour ce premier journal en
direct pour cette nouvelle année je me
fais le porte parole de la rédaction
pour vous souhaiter le meilleur pour les
prochains mois voici les titres
d'aujourd'hui le bras de fer se poursuit
entre l'état et les médecins depuis le
23 décembre de nombreux cabinets sont
fermés ils veulent la réécriture du
projet de loi santé nous en parlerons au
plateau avec nos invités tout à l'heure
à 2015 s'ouvre 2014 est déjà refermé ce
qu'il faut retenir de l'actualité locale
dossier toute cette semaine dans le
journal premier volet ce soir consacrée
aux mois de janvier et de février
pas de nouvel exploit pour mort par deux
forces de basket le petit poucet
s'incline face à caen équipe qui évolue
quatre divisions au dessus nationale 2
c'est avec tristesse que nous ouvrons
cette année avec l annonce de la
disparition de jean pierre beltoise
ancien pilote de formule 1 qui depuis sa
retraite s'était installé dans les
yvelines avec un circuit qui porte son
nom nous sommes en ligne avec le
directeur du site marc baudson directeur
de beltoise évolution dont quatre à
bonsoir à vous oui bonsoir jean pierre
beltoise des cdc le monde automobile qui
est en deuil un double avc survenu à
dakar et on se souviendra de lui comme à
l'homme qui avait aussi relancer le
sport automobile en france au début des
années 60 le monde automobile lui dois
beaucoup
beaucoup mais pas seulement sur le plan
du sport mais aussi sur le plan de
sécurité qui souhaitait le deuxième
combat de sa vie de militer pour
l'amélioration de la sécurité routière
et notamment au travers de son école de
conduite conduire juste les pieds
passivement hébergé sur le site de
trappes
85 grand prix de formule 1 jusqu'en 74
1969 il termine même 5e que vous inspire
sa carrière il a aussi été pilote moto à
onze titres de champion de france
absolument sa carrière c'est le reflet
de son immense talent pour avoir gagné à
la fois à moto
dans les disciplines automobiles aussi
différentes que la formule 1 des sports
prototypes et même le rallycross donc
est également la production si mes
souvenirs sont bons donc c'est quand
même pas de mares et une un éclectisme
qui est assez étonnant
vous l'avez côtoyé puisque vous êtes
donc maintenant aujourd'hui à directeur
du circuit qui porte son nom à trappes
vous le dirai aussi avec ses enfants qui
sont très impliqués il est très présent
il était très présent jusqu'à présent à
jean pierre beltoise
mais j'avais pris quelques distances
mais ils doivent être très présents puis
si vous avez deux à trois visites par
semaine
très amicalement et
avec une grande proximité par rapport à
l'ensemble du personnel qui évidemment
aujourd'hui vous pouvez l'imaginer et
complètement des bascules il avait sept
volontaires de transmettre sa passion de
pour le pour le monde automobile pour le
monde mécanique a parlé de la sécurité
c'est ce qui se poursuivait sur ce site
sur son circuit que vous dirigez
aujourd'hui à la trappe oui absolument
jean pierre avait des idées très
précises sur la manière de réduire la
sinistralité la mortalité routière les
accidents d'une manière plus générale
les notamment en privilégiant un concept
d'anticipation des risques plutôt que
d'essayer de les contrôler mais donc
d'anticiper des risques sous la route de
manière n'est pas se mettre en danger
soi même mais aussi de ne pas mettre en
danger les autres usagers de la route
c'était son grand chez doki n'a pas
arrêté de développer pendant les 25 ou
30 années de la deuxième partie de sa
vie je la conçois créé affecte cause sur
le plan humain puisqu'on parlait du plan
sportif on parlait de ses engagements
pour la sécurité routière mais sur le
plan humain vous qui l'avez côtoyé
quelle image vous avez envie de garder
de lui ce soir c'est l'image d'un homme
exceptionnel ont déjà exceptionnel par
son talent comme on l'a déjà dit 'ne sur
le plan humain c'est quelqu'un que la
célébrité la notoriété avait pas du tout
ça lui est pas monté à la tête de
quelqu'un de très simple très agréable
et très jovial tout plein de projets
très pétillant dans les conversations
pouvait avoir avec lui et n'émettant
aucune distance vis à vis de ses
interlocuteurs dans toutes les questions
et très facile d'abord et c'est tous une
des raisons pour lesquelles il est temps
apprécié par son personnel du cim
surpris mais aussi par les nombreux amis
qu'il a à travers le monde merci marc
baudson directeur de beltoise évolution
attrape merci de ce témoignage jean
pierre beltoise décédé donc à l'âge de
77 ans en ce 5 janvier
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui bernard
cazeneuve le ministre de l'intérieur qui
a présenté ses voeux aux forces de
police à la caserne de crs de vélizy
après plusieurs démonstrations exercice
de la part des forces de police et du
raid le ministre a affirmé son
engagement auprès des fonctionnaires il
aborder entre autres le sujet du
terrorisme
la mutualisation des moyens avec la
gendarmerie ainsi que le mal être des
fonctionnaires de police dont les
suicides augmentent mais avant tout il a
souhaité parler de la modernisation des
forces de l'ordre il a annoncé la
création de 500 postes supplémentaires
et l'augmentation des crédits à
d'investissement et de paiement est coté
dans beaucoup d'endroits il est des
investissements à faire nécessaire sur
lesquels une planification sera élaboré
dans le cadre dit triennal qui permettra
en toute transparence d'indiquer la ou
les efforts sont à faire et là où ils
seront faits et puis juste cette
information concernant la préfecture de
versailles et la sous-préfecture de
mantes-la-jolie les services des deux
établissements seront fermés
exceptionnellement au public demain à
partir de 12 heures 30 nous faisons une
parenthèse avec l'actualité du jour nous
parlons tout à l'heure de la
mobilisation des médecins avec des
invités sur ce plateau on quitte
l'actualité du jour donc je vous le
disais pour notre dossier de la semaine
un dossier consacré à la rétrospective
traditionnel de l'année précédente de
2014 premier volet ce soir que faut-il
retenir de l'actualité à locales sur les
mois de janvier et de février
rappelez-vous mois de janvier 2014 ce
sont les taxis que l'on entend lundi 13
les taxis manifestent à paris pour
dénoncer la concurrence déloyale des
véhicules de tourisme avec chauffeur ils
dénonçaient la différence de traitement
les chauffeurs de taxi be nous appellent
leurs licences 180000 euros contre une
centaine d'euros pour les chauffeurs de
vtc un début d'opérations qui va
s'étaler pendant toute l'année philippe
le plan le faux architectes devant le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles
pour escroquerie et usurpation de
diplômes pendant trente ans cet homme
s'est fait passer pour un architecte
alors qu'il n'avait pas terminé ses
études et qu'il n'en avait pas de
diplôme un procès finalement reporté au
23 juin en ce début d'année fin de
mandat pour le maire de maurepas georges
mougeot ce dernier a choisi de passer la
main moment des élections municipales
élu pour la première fois maire à
maurepas en 89 le maire divers gauche ne
briguera pas un nouveau mandat et vient
d'organiser sa dernière cérémonie de
voeux une page qui se tourne pour la
commune les prétendants seront nombreux
pour prendre sa succession à la tête de
la mairie nous y reviendrons dans notre
rétro du mois de mars et lui aussi il
quitte la vie politique le président de
l'agglomération robert cadalbert ne se
représentera pas pour un nouveau mandat
il ne sera donc pas candidat sur une
liste aux élections municipales il était
président de l'agglomération depuis 16
ans déclarations faites lors des voeux
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
inauguration aussi en janvier en grande
pompe du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une soirée
ponctuée par des duel
france/grande-bretagne qui n'avait
d'amico que le nom le nouvel hymne y
monte à 1 françois pervis a donc été le
premier coureur à s'imposer sur la piste
du vélodrome février maintenant
l'université a bien du mal à boucler son
budget nouveau conseil d'administration
de l'université ce vendredi 14 février
et comme il y à un mois jour pour jour
c'est le même budget en déséquilibre qui
a été présenté il n'a pu être validée
nouveau et dernier délai le 1er mars les
syndicats s'inquiètent de la baisse des
moyens la présidence de vue vs qu assure
qu'une dotation exceptionnelle du
ministère sera octroyé ce qui sera
d'ailleurs le cas l'aider économique
devons être lisez et puis nous terminons
sa pop première rétro de l'année 2014
avec cette manifestation des licenciés
du club de football de trappes ils se
sont réunis devant la mairie pour crier
leur dépit face à distille l'indécence
de leurs infrastructures où il n'y
aurait plus d'entraînement depuis un
mois et demi pour certains enfants une
situation qui avait conduit à la
démission du président du club mustapha
allaoui depuis le club a obtenu
satisfaction
retrospect a retrospective pardon
préparé par catherine solano la suite à
découvrir dès demain dans le journal et
tous les volets seront retrouvés sur
notre site internet comme l'ensemble de
nos reportages après 2014 qu'attendez
vous pour 2015 vos résolutions micro
trottoir donc il peut de nos familles
déjà
priorité
travail m'occuper des autres
des idées d'un d'entre elles de
solidarité arrêter de fumer tout
simplement mais c'est très dur je pense
pas perdre du poids mais ça c'est
évident mais c'est surtout pour mon
mariage qui sera en août la chanter
d'avoir que tout le monde soit on doit
me sentais occuper encore plus de mes
petits enfants par un peu plus de
patience peut-être parfois tout
simplement
vendredi nous vous proposions de
découvrir bernard bitu passionné
d'automobile aujourd'hui retour sur sa
journée rencontre dédicace autour de son
dernier livre c'était samedi à la ferme
du manet à montigny le bretonneux
une journée de partage autour du sport
automobile à la ferme du manet de
montigny le bretonneux voilà le cadeau
de bernard battu pour ce début d'année
qui conviait les amateurs à re découvrir
cet univers à l'occasion de la sortie de
son livre
ouah
qui m'a conduit à représenter des
véhicules dans leur
quotidien avec des photos représentant
les voitures qui n'étaient pas d une
voiture d'époque
de musée mais c'était vraiment une
voiture quotidienne dans cet ouvrage
bernard vie tu raconte son parcours de
conducteurs mais aussi la précision des
réparations techniques
j'ai commencé ma première voiture avec
l'acca de chevaux quatre chevaux et ma
première panne avec le moteur dans le
band sac donc bien toujours des amis qui
sont
plus férus de l'autre en mécanique et
c'est une première aventure c'est de
refaire le moteur à travers ses photos
et ses anecdotes bernard biture revient
avec nostalgie sur une époque où
l'automobile était un plaisir une bonne
occasion de raviver des souvenirs chaque
fois qu'il ya des réunions comme ça où
il ya des voitures
tout le monde a des histoires racontées
sur sa première voiture on parlait de
chevaux tout à l'heure avec grands
volants les vitres qui tombaient
régulièrement
les essuie glaces qui fonctionner
manuellement presque donc ça a beaucoup
changé l'automobile mais c'était aussi
très sympathique pour l'occasion bernard
duthu a présenté sa collection de
miniatures mais a aussi fait venir un
véritable modèle d'époque sa favorite la
f2 arc c'est la voiture que je le
pouvais pas celle là mais une identique
avec un moteur de 15 centimètres cubes
et à fait sûrs pendant votre voiture
c'est la taille de guêpe même si bernard
by tu ne cours plus aujourd'hui
l'automobile c'est toute sa vie une vie
remplie de course de pannes et de
plaisir qui propose de découvrir à
travers son lieu
du sport automobile aux sports sur les
terrains de basket à présent après son
exploit historique face à barjouville le
basket club de maurepas avait l'occasion
de poursuivre son épopée en 64e de
finale de coupe de france face à caen
pensionnaire de nationale 2 mais cette
fois les quatre divisions d'écart on
était trop importante résumé anthony
rech
s'il est mort passe bien débutent la
rencontre avec 25 points d'avancé à
cause de l'écart de quatre divisions à
la faveur de caen leur avance fond comme
neige au soleil à la fin du premier
quart le bcm ne mène plus que de quatre
petits points 33 29 avec six joueurs au
delà des 2 m contre un seul pour le bcm
la supériorité athlétique caennaise fait
logiquement la différence dans la
raquette chaque panier devient alors un
combat pour les rouge et blanc mais
grâce à un gymnase mal me donne une
nouvelle fois omniprésent les joueurs
d'alexis dumontet continuent de se
battre sur chaque possession malgré les
28 points d'avance pour caen après trois
quart temps on avait retenu la leçon du
tour précédent ou même avec un point
d'avancé pour mon papa il avait été
capable de tenir ce score là contre une
équipe de nationale 3 et donc on était
prévenus on savait une salle chaude on
savait une équipe qui jouait avec
enthousiasme et on a surtout été
vigilant
cette fois l'enthousiasmé les supporters
n'ont rien pu faire face à la
supériorité normande une équipe qui n'a
connu qu'une seule défaite en
championnat cette saison score final 106
à 63 la défaite est sans appel mail
aventures du bcm aura été belle
quand on reçoit l'équipe de caen qui est
quand même une grosse équipe de n2 et
sur l'a 39 victoires pour 4 défaites sur
les 2 dernières saisons donc c'est
vraiment une grosse à une grosse écurie
voilà le score il est bien important
robert 43 points mais les joueurs sont
battus ils ont mouillé le maillot et
c'est tout
et rendez vous juste après ce journal
sur tv fil 78 pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 sport avec anthony rech toujours et
sont donc encore en grève les médecins
poursuivent leur mouvement engagé le 23
décembre le bras de fer continue avec
l'état cette fois ci sur le terrain
administratif après une grève des gardes
et des fermetures de cabinets les
médecins décident maintenant de
boycotter la carte vitale de certains
patients une nouvelle méthode pour
maintenir la pression contre la
généralisation du tiers payant l'une des
mesures phares du futur projet de loi
santé du gouvernement yann torres
après la grève et la fermeture de son
cabinet médical patriciens reprend son
activité ce lundi par une visite à
domicile mais comme bon nombre de
médecins elle n'a pas dit son dernier
mot désormais elle refusera la carte
vitale de certains de ses patients
retour aux feuilles de soins papier que
le malade devra lui-même envoyé à la
sécurité sociale pour se faire
rembourser
l'objectif est clairement affiché
engorger les services de l'assurance
maladie a priori elle est quand même
fait pour ça puisque nous qui prenons
sur notre temps pour s'occuper des
remboursements des patients savait
difficile pour eux de pouvoir se
remettre à traiter les feuilles de soins
donc effectivement il y aura des délais
de remboursement probablement qui
atteindront un mois et pour certains
patients ça peut poser un problème donc
évidemment pour cela on utilisera la
carte vitale les médecins la firme ce
n'est pas contre le tiers-payant qu'ils
se mobilisent mais surtout contre son
obligation et sa généralisation une
mesure inscrite au projet de loi santé
que le gouvernement veut faire voter au
printemps 2015 et que ce médecin décrit
comme inapplicable il faut qu'on sache
liés d'une part par la sécurité sociale
dont les sites sont régulièrement en
panne la part de ces trois jours qu'on
ne peut pas accéder aussi de la sécurité
sociale donc impossible de se faire
payer évidemment si on était en tiers
payant et surtout par les mutuelles il y
a près de 500 mutuel en france il faut
qu'on recherche à quelle mutuelle est
affilié le patient rechercher les
impayés globalement tous ceux qui le
pratiquent aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
pharmaciens les centres de santé et
certains médecins dans par exemple sur
l'île de la réunion nous disent que ça
leur revient à peu près à 3 euros 50 par
pacte entre inquiétude et compréhension
les avis des patients eux sont mitigés
si on reprend les feuilles de soins
c'est beaucoup plus long pour se faire
rembourser et moi je pourrais je suis
pas d'accord et puis rien on est pris en
otage quand on va chez le médecin il est
normal de payer sa
facture sauf pour les gens qui n'ont pas
les moyens et là il est tout à fait
normal que
la carte vitale servent dans ce cas là
pour l'instant pas de réponse précise de
la part du gouvernement la grève de la
carte vitale continue jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
et nous sommes en ligne à présent pour
continuer à évoquer ce sujet avec le
docteur laurent de bastard bonsoir vous
êtes membre du syndicat des médecins
libéraux vice présidents vice-présidents
également de l'ordre des médecins
urgentistes on entendait dans le
reportage qui vient d'être diffusé le
témoignage de certains patients qui
avaient le sentiment d'être un peu pris
en otage avec cette histoire de carte
vitale qui ne sera pas accepter ça va
retarder pénaliser les remboursements
quelle réponse vous pouvez apporter à
ces patients qui qui s'inquiètent
que je voudrais surtout l'exaspération
des médecins qui sont exaspérés pas
écoutés par le gouvernement qu'ils ont
depuis le mois d'octobre le président du
conseil national de l'ordre a demandé
avec une concertation à ce sujet sur la
mise en place du tiers-payant
obligatoires et puis ils sont inquiets
justement par ces mesures
deux tiers payant généralisé et après il
ya 102 syndicats médicaux qui ont
demandé en effet à ce qu'il y ait des
feuilles de soins qui ferait fait je
crois que ce sera fait au cas par cas et
en tous les cas jamais pour pénaliser
les patients pour vous c'est une bonne
idée éventuellement en tout cas c'est un
moyen de pression qui peut être efficace
sans trop avoir l'opinion publique qui
se retourne contre vous c'est ça ce sera
fait apparemment pas tous ont cité mais
qui paie vraiment cas par cas et si
c'est la seule façon pour les médecins
se faire entendre parce que là ils ont
déjà été en rêve et d'aujourd'hui sont
les établissements privés et les
cliniques privées qui sont en grève dans
toute la france et apparemment de façon
à
il ferait la santé marisol touraine dit
qu'il se passe rien alors qu'on sait que
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital de versailles où
alfred kouassi il ya des attentes au
delà de 12 heures avec plus de 80 à 100
patients c'est la tente
c'est la seule façon encore une fois de
faire entendre pourquoi pas mais
peut-être une réaction à présent sur une
déclaration qui a été faite ce matin
c'était par le secrétaire général de la
confédération française démocratique du
travail la cfdt laurent berger qui
disait ne pas soutenir la grève des
médecins contre le projet de loi santé
il ya une division aujourd'hui auprès
des différents syndicats est ce que vous
êtes dans le même ordre de marche dans
le même sens aujourd'hui
en tous les cas match où elle a réussi à
faire l'unanimité tous les cinq années
fait pas ce qu'il veut de droite de
bouche il ya unanimité tous les médecins
ont appelé à la grève dès le début du
mois du mois de janvier pour la période
des fêtes alors même si le pays
concordants sur sur la période tous ont
appelé à la grève en france qui dut du
café obligatoire les médecins qui
exercent et qu'il faut régler leurs
patients considère justement ce fait
demandé à ce que ce soit pas le cas sur
les services d'urgence hospitaliers
parce que on sait que la santé d'autant
plus coûteuse que cela ne coûtera rien à
personne et que aujourd'hui une
consultation chez un médecin généraliste
ses 23 euros à ce qui est le plus bas en
europe et
alors qu'un concours ceux
ci on doit résumer ce soir le principal
point d'opposition entre les médecins le
secteur de la santé et le gouvernement
se serait la question du tiers-payant
justement qui serait réalisée qu'est ce
qui bloque le plus qu est ce qui pose
problème et sur lequel les médecins le
monde de la santé ne veut pas transiger
aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment le point d'achoppement
qui est une très mauvaise idée puisque
elle sera reçue recouvre attentes et sa
façon unanime tout le monde a conscience
5,6 c'est gratuit les gens vont
consommer plus et ça va coûter plus cher
donc c'est pas une bonne idée
aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas de difficulté avec ce soin
de
financier puisque quand les passionnants
pas le
dessus 6 ans ils ont la cmu
l'étranger hélas le seul difficultés
d'accès aux soins aujourd'hui c'est à
discuter démographique c'est à dire on
est arrivé une telle pénurie de médecins
en france et même maintenant en
ile-de-france que qu'il y ait des
difficultés pour faire soigner donc
c'est surtout une heure un problème de
démographie médicale et ça parce que la
forme de médecins aussi ne veulent pas
s'installer parce que la profession le
métier
difficile merci docteur laurent de
bastard avoir été en ligne avec nos
membres du syndicat des médecins
libéraux vice présidents ou vice
président de l'ordre des médecins
urgentistes merci pour votre témoignage
on va continuer en plateau a évoqué à ce
dossier pour la fin de ce journal avec à
présent j'accueille à présent par don le
docteur ida marineland les bienvenus
vous êtes du syndicat national des
jeunes médecins généralistes on vient
d'entendre leurs représentants des
médecins libéraux aujourd'hui tous les
médecins qu'ils soient libéraux
généralistes peu importe vous êtes tous
dans le même sens de marche dans le même
dans la même union contre ce projet de
réforme pour les mêmes raisons alors
justement quelles sont les raisons vos
motivations dans un communiqué vous
appeler pour de même 6 janvier
avec une mobilisation avec une marche à
partir du ministère de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche vers le
ministère des affaires sociales et de la
santé ça sera à paris vous dites que ce
projet de loi va démanteler votre métier
dans l'ensemble c'est ça oui en fait ce
qu'on ce qu'on voit c'est que on va
manquer de médecins généralistes de plus
en plus et que ce projet de loi on fait
comment vous dire et dispersent les
compétences mais il ne laisse pas le
médecin généraliste là où il a peut-être
c'est à dire il doit être le pivot du
système de soins donc on va dire
on va dire voilà on va donner telle
compétence at-elle profession à telle
autre mais ça va être dispersée et du
coup ça va faire une médecine à bas prix
si on peut dire et voilà ce qu'on craint
c'est que c'est notre métier qu'on est
en train de démanteler en dehors du
suivi des patients vous évoquez les
consultations plafonné à 23 euros si
encore le manque de moyens est là en
tant que jeunes médecins sortis
intéressant c'est sur la formation des
moyens sur la formation aussi
également donc on parle de formation
c'est à dire que pour les internes et
donc un interne en médecine générale
entre autres est un médecin à plein
temps à l'hôpital donc il ya déjà plein
temps l'hôpital mais est également
étudiant en troisième cycle à
l'université toujours à plein temps et
donc aujourd'hui la question est le
temps de travail des internes nous on se
bat pour une semaine à 48 heures au lieu
de 70 80 mes sources et 48 heures c'est
sur cinq jours du lundi au vendredi avec
deux demi journées de formation comprise
dans le temps de travail ce qui nous
ramènerait avec quatre jours on aurait
donc 40 heures le cinquième jour deux
fois quatre heures deux études ça nous
apportera 48 en plus il aura bien sûr
l'égard des autres mais c'est ça qu'on
demande alors qu'on nous propose une
seule demi-journée dans le temps de
travail et l'autre demi journée c'est la
nuit ou les week-ends quand on peut vous
expliquer en introduction de votre
propos tout à l'heure vous êtes
mobiliser tous ensemble tous les
médecins mais pas pour les mêmes raisons
on l'a bien compris juste avant tout à
l'heure l'autre témoignage on entendait
parler du tiers-payant qui était le
principal principal point de blocage là
aussi la généralisation du tiers-payant
c'est quelque chose qui vous inquiète ça
ne pose pas vraiment de problème puisque
si vous voulez il faut que ce soit bien
fait quand si vous pré en exemple la cmu
c'est parfaitement gérer donc il faut
que ça soit jamais il ne faut pas que ce
soit aux médecins d'aller solliciter les
mutuelles pour se faire rembourser il
faut que si c'est bien géré il n'y aura
aucun problème donc pour nous ça ne pose
pas de problème le tiers payant il faut
juste que ce soit bien fait vous allez
donc vous mobiliser demain il y à cette
mobilisation aussi danger auprès de
certains certains professionnels de
santé de ne plus accepter cette carte
vitale peut-être cela vous est déjà
arrivé ces derniers jours même
aujourd'hui de voir cette carte vitale
refusé afin de faire pression c'est le
moyen décidé par certains médecins de
faire pression sur le gouvernement on a
le sentiment que parmi toutes les
revendications qui s'exprime c'est que
le système de santé aujourd'hui en
france ne marche pas ils ont qu'il ne
marche pas comme il devrait marcher
c'est pas qu'il ne marche pas mais là
nous nous sommes nous n'avons pas appelé
à boycotter comment vous dire la carte
vitale parce que la fête ça va être les
patients qui vont être quand même
pénalisé puisque c'est eux qui vont être
remboursés avec du retard du coup nous
on a pas d'accord sur le mode d'action
et les moyens qu'ils ont mais même en a
on a chacun qu'on vous diront on a
chacun nos motifs d'actions et sur le
système de santé qui globalement ne
fonctionneraient pas comme il devrait
quels sont les points sur lesquels il
faudrait travailler justement quel
message vous fait passer aujourd'hui il
faudrait qu'une part qu' une
concertation avec les médecins avec la
base avec notamment avec les syndicats
le nôtre en particulier aussi et qu'on
nous demande notre avis qu on demande
leur avis à ceux qui sont sur le terrain
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire ce dont
vous avez besoin et on a l'impression
que c'est toujours les bureaucrates qui
décide dans leur coin très loin de la
réalité demain vous serez mobilisés sur
le terrain pour cette mobilisation
manifestation 6 janvier à paris elle
départ devant le ministère
d'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche merci d'être venus jusqu'à
nous je sais que vous êtes paris c'était
compliqué pour venir jusque là et vous
êtes passé sur ce plateau quelques
instants pour exprimer votre témoignage
merci beaucoup d'être venu c'est la fin
de ce journal à présent se retrouvent
demain le toujours à 18h en direct tout
de suite sur tv fil 78 7 8 sport avec
anthony rech
vous